good morning Chris how are you yeah
morning dan I was going to guess a
billion dollars I've never seen him work
a day in his life so this is kind of fun
let's play let's play with your salary
oh okay
clear Bank Curry and then we'll do yours
- how much did you make when you played
for the Bengals first year a hundred
thousand dollars I thought I was the
richest man on earth
got a $200,000 signing bonus I went to
the bank and ask for it in pennies you
did not did I knew the banker course
what did you did you splurge on anything
you know I was scared to death - I
really was I was so afraid that I was
going to get cut and humiliated and you
know so I drove my Bobcat that's what I
had in college a bobcat which is not
quite a Pinto and I drove it until about
we 13 in the season that I bought a
Porsche oh look at you yes sir did you
have vanity plates no I didn't even know
what that was that mean Boomer Esiason
probably had vanity plates I'm trying to
think if he did or not I'm not sure that
he did I'm not he was the first human
being I ever knew to make a million
dollars so I do remember that and he
stole his first paycheck well he was the
MVP
one year - oh yeah yeah we were lucky we
had two MVPs and Cincinnati while I
played Kenny won MVP and 81 and Boomer
in 88
I had Maurice jones-drew on a couple of
days ago and he made a strong argument
about you know what know your Worth and
if he was lady on bail he would sit out
until week ten and he was saying look as
a running back and he understands
exactly what Le'Veon Bell is doing and
why he has this thought process can you
make a case for what lay beyond Bell is
doing yeah I can't there's a handful of
guys that can impact
running game and the passing game the
way that that he can and I do think
they're worth more you know Adrian
Peterson was a great player and is a
great player had a good game the other
day but he's not going to impact the
passing game and and I think that lay
beyond probably justifiably looks at
Pittsburgh and says if I go back you
know they're I'm gonna get twenty five
touches a game and if I get hurt then
you know I'm out of luck so he has to
play six games to become vested and
probably moving on from there so I think
that's exactly what he's doing I I hear
incredible things around the league
right now I mean things that we would
have never even considered doing had
somebody on the team the other day tell
me that guys are refusing to play on the
kickoff team I was like what he said
yeah he said they go you know look at
the look at the statistics it's too
dangerous I'm not playing on there I was
trying to imagine telling Flores Greg
that I'm not playing on anything you
know I mean there was there was such a
fear factor with with how we thought of
our team and of course there was no free
agency when I played but you just
wouldn't dare do anything like that
because you didn't have other options
but also if you're a teammate in his
offensive linemen called e-mount which I
found surprising I did I did and you
think they're just gonna welcome him
with open arms in week ten and want to
block for him and say hey you know we're
great you got I'm glad you're back you
got fresh legs and helped us get to the
playoffs you think that is can you have
can you compartmentalize this if you're
the steelers offensive line no but i get
it on both ends right i mean they
they're pittsburgh clearly knows he's
one of their best players so they're
frustrated that he's not coming back but
the general rule in the NFL has always
been you don't mess with another man's
money right if he's holding out and he's
looking for a better contract the other
players on the team were going to
support dec so it's always sort of us
against down and management and you know
you never get paid enough and all that
kind of stuff no you know it I don't
know if it runs a little deeper you know
is there something we don't know about
the relationship between the offensive
line and Le'Veon Bell maybe there is a
feeling that you know hey how about
giving us a little credit for some of
the numbers that you put up and that is
a really good offensive line but I think
that you know the Todd Gurley deal kind
of set the set the bar for that one and
unfortunately you know they're still
saying the running back position is you
know doesn't have that kind of value
because of the injury right well part of
the injury rate is you're using them 25
times a game used to be 25 times the
game I'm not confident you know there's
logic on both ends of it he's Chris
Collinsworth NBC Sunday Night Football
analysts we got the Giants and the
Cowboys coming up Sunday night Ross
Tucker was on a former NFL player and he
said that he thinks Sam darn 'old right
now might be as good as Eli Manning I
tell you for the Giants it was a game of
missed opportunities so I don't know
that I'm I'm quite ready to go there yet
although Sam Darnell has been really
impressive all the way through is
impressive in college that's a tough
choice
you know the PSF guys that I have are
all about the analytics of the thing
and even though say Quan Barclay was
great and in week one the chance of
getting a franchise quarterback at any
point right and no matter when you're
drafting even if you're drafting number
one overall sometimes is not very good
so there was a real debate in our
building really wasn't much of a debate
our guys that they should have taken Sam
Darnell no matter how good sake one
Barkley was so you know but I still
think what's interesting about watching
the Giants is that they have so many
great weapons on that offense and I
thought Odell look tremendous they
certainly have the ability
made some big plays a adele had a chance
in that game if they don't miss some
overthrows and you know the Jaguars
takes some some penalties instead of
letting Odell get behind them they miss
a cover zero easy throw to the post
because of some immediate pressure they
had a chance for Odell to have over 200
yards receiving and his first game back
and but it's Dallas looked like that - I
mean Dallas looked like it was a third
preseason game the mistakes they made in
that game are ordinarily mistakes you
make in a third preseason game but
because nobody's playing the third
preseason game anymore there's tear
there's mistakes come on opening day and
I thought both teams look like that
Jerry Jones was doing his weekly radio
show on the fan in Dallas he had this to
say about dak Prescott we've got a
quarterback that there is somewhere
between the one that you saw with the
Rams last night and somewhere and camlet
he can do some of what both of those
guys - there's no lad each in looking
and evaluating a player if you've seen
them do it a few times they can do it
and if you've seen them do it well
frankly all of our fans have seen dak do
it well you know it's there you know
he's got it is that good enough to have
a quarterback who's in between golf and
camp well depends on where you're trying
to get I guess it's it's I would that's
that's not far off but what I saw was an
offense that was uncomfortable I mean
just uncomfortable they they didn't look
good at all and it wasn't it wasn't the
protection I thought for the most part
the protection in the game I'm just
about finished with the fourth quarter
now watching the tape I thought the
protection was really good they've got
an issue a wide receiver
they really don't I can't remember a
single throw you know I'm about 10
minutes to go in the game I can't
remember a single throw down the field
other than the one is short hop to the
tight end in a blown coverage so if you
don't have that down the field stretch
filled kind of threat you end up with a
swishy offense you know you end up with
an offense that's sort of playing with
all within 15 yards and really Carolina
they started off the game and main
coverage and played a lot of it and and
had controlled the wide receivers then
ended up switching to some real basic
cover to Tampa to kind of looks and it
would it just looked like it sort of
befuddled the Cowboys you know I'm sure
they're going to go back and look at
that and say we've got to get back to
who we are but Luke Kuechly was killing
them in the run game there was nowhere
to run the football they had some core
base runs that look pretty good that
they should have run more times you know
when they end up pulling Zach Martin and
pulled the center typically Travis
Frederick now Joe Looney at around that
I think they ran for 10 yards every time
they ran it so I think they'll get back
to some basics I really believe they
have to get back to running dak Prescott
you know some read-option stuff they ran
one thing that kind of looked like an
RPO and hit it and a slant and never
came back to it again so there's some
things that worked but not much it was
it was a pretty tough day for the
Cowboys you guys of course were on the
call for the Packers and the Bears and
the Aaron Rodgers come back a couple of
questions with this I'm curious if he
hadn't signed that big contract do you
think that Aaron Rodgers would have
played in the second half against the
Bears interesting question I'm sure he
gave him more confidence to come out
there play in the second half I'm gonna
guess you would have with the game of
the question I raised during the game as
if the Bears had scored they went down
and made at 20 to nothing was a field
goal if they'd scored a touchdown what
do you have come back at 24 to nothing
and come back and played in the game I
maybe I you know you just don't know but
that was that was what we used to see
out of Brett Favre and that was what we
used to love about Brett was no matter
what happened to him physically he found
a way to play in the game and keep that
Canseco
game streak alive and and when some
games like that I don't know if Brett
maybe the day his father passed away but
that was as impressive to see him out
there on one leg and not be able to tour
it around on that left knee that was
about the best-known Aaron Rodgers you
know I'm he's had some phenomenal games
but you had that element of the injury
into it and coming back in the Willis
Reed and the whole thing that was about
the best I've seen out of out of Aaron
Rodgers I still find it fascinating how
we try to quantify Aaron Rodgers
greatness that you know Tom Brady's the
greatest of all time and then followed
by Joe Montana and John Elway or
whatever order but Aaron Rodgers is
always labeled as the most talented
quarterback to play the position like
how is history going to look at Aaron
Rodgers if let's say the resume doesn't
include another Super Bowl just a lot of
great numbers the touchdown to
interception ratio is going to be
wonderful but if you only have one and
you're considered the most talented
quarterback in history how do we look at
Aaron Rodgers when it's all done I think
he's the most talented overall guy I
mean no John Elway Bert Jones you put a
few guys in that physically Mike Vick
Randall Cunningham just as far as the
physical skills that are sort of
superior to everybody else blah blah
blah but I'll tell you the what I don't
think people talk about nearly enough
you know this is a guy that one
celebrity jeopardy I must start there
his recall is almost second to none
among people I've ever met that play any
that do anything
forget playing the football but as far
as playing the quarterback position he
has the ability to recall things I mean
you can ask him about a drive that
happened 10 years ago
and he'll take you through the entire
Drive I mean it is it's if he doesn't
have a photographic memory he has
something pretty close to it so his
decision-making and ability to
manipulate the defense I
think is way underrated just how purely
intelligent the man is is way underrated
then you throw in is movement skills you
throw in that little flick of an arm
motion you throw in all the off-balance
throws I remember that playoff game that
we did against Arizona he moved to his
left and threw a Hail Mary 60 yards off
balance that by play he swears he's
practice before so yeah as far as just
overall complete package of a
quarterback I you know I'd be
hard-pressed to come up with what I
thought was more impressive if I said
you can have Brady or Rodgers at the
peak in their prime
I think Brady has a lot of those things
that I just talked about and he would be
my top two or three as far as recall
Peyton Manning another guy on that list
you know Russell Wilson is one of those
guys that can do some of the stuff that
I'm talking about Tom Brady obviously
never had the physical movement skills
that Aaron Rodgers has I do think he had
the arm strength I think people greatly
under a sunder estimated his arm
strength Brady's arm strength over the
years he has certainly had the
intelligence but I just think the
movement skills would have separated if
you're just going forget Super Bowls and
numbers and all that stuff physically
what they could do I think Rodgers would
be a little bit let's see you take
Rogers over Brady yeah just because of
the physical movement skills yeah have
fun in Dallas Chris great to talk to you
again tell al and Michelle we set a low
and we'll be watching
but that's Cris Collinsworth NBC Sunday
Night Football
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]